Following another choice tweet and a new
tell-all book, a group of psychiatrists
are publicly warning – now more than ever –
that the president is dangerous, and
urging that he be removed from access to
weapons. These psychiatrists are
expressing a view that millions of
Americans share – and millions reject – and
claiming that their expertise as mental
health professionals adds authority. But
does it? As a psychiatrist, I say no. They
have no greater insight into Trump's
behavior, and thus his fitness for office.
When they claim to, they politicize our
profession. His grandiosity and
impulsivity were evident during the
campaign and earlier. They're his baseline
features! Had his personality undergone
rapid deterioration, affected his ability
to govern, then the Cabinet and Congress
would likely ask psychiatrists for a
diagnosis, treatment options, and a
prognosis in the course of invoking the
25th Amendment to deprive him of his
powers. But ultimately, this is a
political process, not a medical one. Whatever
one thinks of Mr. Trump, his actions
and words are on display for all to see.
The public doesn't need experts to
interpret them.
Should psychiatrists comment publicly on the mental health of the president? Let us know in your
comments. Also, let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds, and be sure to like and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI.